la conférence du dialogue social
souhaité par le premier ministre s'est
achevée peu avant 13 heures elle
réunissait plusieurs ministres dont la
ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes les syndicats les
partenaires sociaux alors jean castex
s'est dit satisfait de ces échanges il a
loué les qualités de responsabilité des
partenaires sociaux et surtout
évidemment le bilan très attendu et que
les concertations concernant les
réformes attendrait comme le souhaitait
d'ailleurs les syndicats alors premier
dossier épineux l'assurance chômage
un premier volet était entré en vigueur
en novembre un second devait entrer en
vigueur en septembre ça avait été reculé
à cause de la crise du coronavirus et
bien finalement la nouvelle échéance est
porté à 2021
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex à
ce sujet la réforme de l'assurance
chômage est une bonne réforme et nous la
mènerons à terme mais nous avons parce
que nous sommes pragmatiques décidé de
l'adapter aux circonstances
concernant le dossier explosif des
retraites est bien là aussi les
discussions attendre on sait que les
syndicats ne voulaient pas en entendre
parler ni cet été ni à la rentrée mais
le patronat également s'était aligné sur
cette décision
alors crise oblige les négociations
attendront on écoute jean castex
l'instauration d'un nouveau régime de
retraite universel sur lequel monsieur
le président de la république s'est
engagé en 2010 est devant le peuple
français sera maintenu simplement comme
je lé indiqué aux partenaires sociaux
nous les appliquerons une nouvelle
méthode d'abord en distinguant très
clairement le caractère structurel de
cette réforme qui vise à plus de justice
de tous ses éléments financiers
en reprenant la concertation dans les
mois à venir pour en améliorer le
contenu et la lisibilité par nos
concitoyens
c'est une affaire extrêmement importante
alors est-ce reculer pour mieux sauter
en tout cas jean castex a bien réagi
mais vouloir mener à bien ses réformes
qu'il juge nécessaire il a expliqué que
des divergences surviendront mais
qu'elles étaient le lot de la démocratie
sociale en tout cas pour lui la priorité
à l'heure actuelle et la relance
la priorité et l'emploi en tout cas
voilà comment s'est conclue cette
journée d'échangés entre le premier
ministre et les partenaires sociaux
jean castex a en outre annoncé une autre
journée de conférence sociale en octobre